hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll the big news
in mindscape land as you may have heard
is that I've opened a patreon account
that is in other words a way that you
can send me money for me making podcasts
this is something I've been thinking
about for a while you know as much as I
love the podcasting I do love it and I
wouldn't do it if I didn't enjoy it and
in many ways it's an excuse for me to
talk to interesting people about topics
that I wouldn't ordinarily get to think
about it also takes time and it even
takes money and so forth so being
recompence in some way is a good thing
even though the podcast is relatively
young I've already gotten a few emails
from different people different
companies who are interested in placing
ads on the podcast this is the
traditional way that people can support
their podcasting efforts the hosts will
read and add in the beginning or in the
middle and talk about how wonderful this
particular smoothie is or that
particular penknife or whatever it is
that is being sold at the time I don't
really have moral objections to that
it's you know how commerce works so I
wouldn't advertise something that I
didn't like I would actually be very
careful about what it was that was being
advertised but I do have some aesthetic
worries you know I just like it better
when the podcast is nothing but the
substance of what we're talking about
and not being interrupted by ads so the
idea behind the patreon is to replace
the revenue that would come in from ads
with just people giving money in
exchange for receiving the podcast so
you can go to patreon and Comm
Sean M Carroll or you can just go to the
mindscape podcast home page preposterous
universe comm slash podcast and there's
links there to the patreon page and then
you can pledge so what that means is you
agree to give $1 or $2 or $5 or $10 or
or whatever amount of money you want to
pledge that will be for every individual
episode so sometimes it's done per month
or per time period
I can't absolutely promise that the rate
of podcasts is going to be exactly the
same every month so I think that it's
more fair
to charge per podcast so $1 per podcast
it's not that much you know it would be
ideal in my world if I could just charge
everybody 10 cents per episode of
podcast
everyone who listened I'm probably
making a lot more money than I would
with ads or patreon or anything else but
there's no such system as far as I know
to make that work maybe someday crypto
currencies will let that happen you'll
be paying me in Bitcoin or something
like that so let's see how this goes if
I can make anywhere close to the income
from patreon that I would from ads then
I prefer to just stick with that and
never have ads but you know no promises
we're trying things I'm learning I'm new
at this so you know let me know what do
you think about it and please if you
like the podcast do you think about
going and pledging I completely
understand if you don't I'm sure that
many listeners you have lower incomes
than I do it's completely okay if you
don't want to pledge it's a bit of a
hassle in a lot of people's minds do you
know go sign up put in your PayPal your
credit card or whatever so I'm not
guilting anyone into doing this this is
completely optional completely voluntary
it's nice it makes me feel good and it
makes you feel good it's a way to give
back to the podcast if you're enjoying
it so I very much appreciate if you do
that I certainly appreciate those of you
who have already signed up thank you
very much it makes me feel like I'm
doing something good and makes me
motivated to do more of it there's also
a slightly more tangible benefit
involved in that I'm going to try to do
monthly or maybe once every two month
and ask me anything an AMA where
subscribers can ask questions patreon is
in other words people who've pledged
something and I will answer them in the
form of a podcast and it will be
available exclusively to the supporters
so for your dollar an episode or two
dollars an episode or whatever you get
to listen to me answer some questions
about something in fact if you go to the
patreon page there are tears that they
they like tears right so you can pledge
at this level or that level all of the
levels get you the same rewards in my
system I'm not doing in any sort of
complicated system where you get more
and more goodies for more and more
because there's a bare-bones operation
that I'm doing in my spare time here the
amount of appreciation goes higher and
higher the more money that comes in but
you'll get the AMAs and you get the
feeling of satisfaction the other thing
to announce is that today we have a
special show in that there are no guests
this is a solo show just me talking the
topic is a big one why does the universe
exist why is there something rather than
nothing why is there anything at all I
will give you an answer I will talk
about various different answers this is
not the kind of question that is really
straightforward to definitively answer
in a way that everyone agrees but I'll
try to sketch out some of the
possibilities it's obviously a big
question the very biggest questions
that's why we're here at the mindscape
podcast so let's go
[Music]
I'm often asked when I first got
interested in science or in physics or
cosmology different people come into a
field like this in different ways some
people don't discover it till rather
late they're in college or something
like that other people discovered rather
early I was in the very early camp I was
a kid
I say that I was 10 years old what I
actually remember it was that it was in
4th grade when I you know in my
classmates and so forth started talking
about science in a in a more directed
way not just whatever was going on in
class that day but I really became
fascinated by it I know a lot of people
became interested because of science
fiction because of movies and TV and
books and whatever for me was actually
nonfiction books I would just read books
in the local public library which I
haunted for many many hours and I would
read books on quarks and the Big Bang
and general relativity and particle
physics quantum mechanics and I said I
want to do this this is what I want to
do for a living and you know it makes
you think right you start thinking about
these great ideas you've never been
exposed to before and I could usually
you know think my way through and maybe
not understand things perfectly but at
least you know come to some comfort
level with the various words and ideas
that were being batted around the one
that always sort of stuck me a little
bit was why is the universe here at all
when I would fall asleep at night you
know thinking about something I'd read
in a cosmology book or whatever at some
point my brain would come on to this
question of you know what if I weren't
even here what if the universe was not
here what then
and then that was it I would no more
sleep for me that night that was the
kind of thing that kept me up at night
that in Bigfoot but that's a whole
nother story so this is a famous problem
right why is universe exist why is there
something rather than nothing is a
famous way of putting it
I'm not an really an expert I'm not sure
what it means to be an expert on this
question I guess I'm more expert than
the average person certainly on the
physics side of things I am pretty well
aware of the relevant issues and I enjoy
talking about reading about learning
about
the philosophical side of things and
even the theological religious side of
things so I was invited to write an
article write a paper about this a
review paper invited by Eleanor Knox and
Alastair Wilson who are two philosophers
of science to an upcoming volume called
the Rutledge companion to the philosophy
of physics and foolishly I said yes
although it was a lot of fun after the
fact you know your memories don't always
correctly reflect how you were feeling
at the time while I was writing it it
was a tremendous hassle but now that
I've written it I remember it as great
fun so you can find the paper online on
my web site or elsewhere it's simply
called why is there something rather
than nothing and I thought that there'll
be a good topic to dive into for my
first ever solo podcast for a number of
different reasons maybe the biggest
reason being that it's sort of a
representative topic for the kinds of
things that I want to talk about as the
podcast goes forward it absolutely
requires that we take seriously the the
Union and certainly the intersection of
physics but also philosophy and as I
said religion you know because one of
the answers is gonna be given for why
their universe exists is that because
God made the universe right that's gonna
be a popular answer I can't deny that so
you have to think about that is that the
right answer what is the evidence one
way or the other does it hold up is it
the best way of thinking about things so
that's what we're gonna do I'm not the
first one to talk about this of course
in fact in very recent years it's the
kind of topic that pops up if you go and
Google why is there something rather
than nothing why does universe exist you
get plenty of hits and I think that
there's been a misimpression that a lot
of people have gotten so part of the
purpose of this particular discussion
will be to correct some misimpressions
the misimpression I'm referring to is
the idea that advances in modern physics
have answered the question why does the
universe exist answered it in a way that
hadn't been answered before and I think
that's just wrong I think that is not
true
advances in modern physics have shed
light on what it means to ask the
question they have given us new ways of
thinking about what would qualify as an
answer but they have not told us what
the answer is
in particular there's a little motto
that goes around saying the reason why
there's something rather than nothing is
because nothing is unstable and this has
something to do with the quantum vacuum
state so I'm here to tell you that is
not answer this question that were
interested in the motto nothing is
unstable was invented by Frank will
checked Nobel prize-winning physicist
and he wasn't really referring to the
question of why there's a universe at
all he was referring to the question of
why there is matter in the universe in
particular why there is more matter than
antimatter and you can try to explain
that we don't know what the right answer
to that question is but you can try to
explain it in terms of the instability
of certain quantum states that's a
perfectly sensible thing to do but why
there are quantum states why there's a
universe at all why there's space-time
is completely unrelated to this
particular thought that was in Frank
will checks mind so you know he's a
brilliant guy he'd understood this
perfectly he knows what he's talking
about but in boiling it down to a motto
I think that it's applicability got a
little lost so that's not the answer in
fact you know I think if there is any
answer to the question of why is there
something rather than nothing the answer
is there isn't an answer the answer is
that the issue of the existence of the
universe is not the kind of thing to
which we can attach why questions and
why answers this is why of course it
becomes a little bit of philosophy that
we talk about well you know what do you
mean by why what do you mean by
something and nothing and that this kind
of discussion might very well be
frustrating or boring to you I get that
no problems with that
you know I'm sympathetic this discussion
is largely not gonna be for you if
you're not that interested in a very
careful rigorous parsing of the meaning
of these questions and how they could
possibly be applicable that's of the
work we have to do to try to understand
what the possible answers could be to
why there's something rather than
nothing so that's the plan for this
discussion I'm going to talk about what
it means to ask why something is true
why something is the case then we're
gonna talk about what it means for there
to be something rather than nothing and
then we can talk about some of the
more down-to-earth physics concerns some
of the ideas that we do have after all
the universal Bayes laws of physics so
what the laws of physics are and how
they apply to the universe
are certainly going to be relevant when
you talk about why there's something
rather than nothing even if they don't
provide a once-and-for-all
answer okay so that's the background
with that background in mind we can
think about the question it's the kind
of question that is so big and obvious
right why is there a universe at all why
does reality exist you might have
thought this was hotly debated 2500
years ago that you know in the Athenian
flowering of science and philosophy
Plato and Aristotle probably bandied
about this question and offered you know
colorful dialogues or extensive treaty
sees about it but no actually as far as
I can tell this was just not a question
they chose to address they had different
opinions about how the universe came to
be Plato has it had his idea of the
Demiurge and so forth
Aristotle invented his idea of the
unmoved mover which is basically God but
the issue of like maybe the universe
couldn't have existed or might not have
existed and was not really a hot topic
back then it wasn't until Leibniz in the
18th century Gottfried Wilhelm Leibniz
one of the co discoverers of calculus
along with Isaac Newton Leibniz was a
very influential philosopher and
physicist even though the word physicist
wasn't that popular back in the day it
was live knits who first posed the
question in the modern form why is there
something rather than nothing
it was later dubbed the primordial
existential question and it's a good one
yeah we can we can ask it anyway we
can't demand it that there is a
satisfactory answer this is going to be
part of my sales pitch here it's
perfectly good to ask questions like
this but when you are dealing at the
very boundaries of knowledge the things
that we don't have familiarity with in
our everyday lives what you can't do is
simply insist before you even dig into
the question that it's going to be the
kind of thing that's going to give you
the kind of answer you used to I mean
why would it it's a very different kind
of question the renewal
nearly faced within our day-to-day lives
live minutes in particular had slightly
hidden agenda it wasn't very hidden it
was an open agenda he was trying to
develop an idea that he had called the
principle of sufficient reason the
principle of sufficient reason is
basically the bumper sticker that you
can get that says everything happens for
a reason basically he says that anything
that occurs in the world does so for a
good reason
there's a reason why now this is one of
those things that seems reasonable right
now when we see things happen they don't
just randomly happen there seems to be a
pattern and orderliness to nature so
things happen for reasons why and
Leibniz says this is a rule he says in
other words it's not just something we
happen to notice that things happen for
reasons it's something that will always
be true an absolute foundational
principle of how reality works and if
you say that then of course the
existence of the universe is something
that has a reason the universe happens
it exists Seligman says clearly there's
a reason why the universe happens so
live Nets in his philosophy was I know
what the reason why is it's God God
created the universe that's a very
simple answer now as very clever
sophisticated highly educated 21st
century thinkers I'm sure you're sitting
there thinking but wait a minute what is
the reason that God exists isn't there a
worry of an infant regress here and live
minutes he's thought of this he's way
ahead of you he says no no God is his
own reason that's the unique thing about
God unlike the universe which may or may
not have existed God necessarily exists
so God is the one thing that doesn't
need an external reason doesn't need a
reason other than himself God has his
own reason for existing and he's the
reason for everything else existing so
if you can buy that if you can buy into
this framework it is at least consistent
right it's at least self-contained it
does provide answers to the questions
that we've been posed it's not
necessarily been a very popular idea
since then it depends on your attitude
towards other questions roughly speaking
if you're religious this sounds like a
good strategy everything needs a reason
the universe's reason is God God's
reason
his ownself people like David Hume
scoffed at the idea later on the famous
Scottish philosopher David Hume who was
one of my intellectual mentors in some
sense David Hume is someone I didn't
think that much of when I first
encountered him in college but then
again I went to a Catholic University
and we studied the parts of David Hume
that were less interesting and now I
realize in my old age that Hume is right
about a lot of things you can learn a
lot by reading David Hume and Hume just
says look I don't see any reason why
there should be a necessary being how do
you know that something like God is a
necessary thing and Hume pointed out he
didn't spend a lot of time on it but
it's basically our basic argument which
I think is correct is look all of your
arguments in favor of the idea that God
is a necessary being basically are
circular they basically come down to the
idea that you insist that everything has
a reason that nothing can just be if you
don't insist on that then the universe
can just be and if you do insist on that
then you're cooking the books
if you insist that everything has a
reason then yes you get to this result
but maybe some things don't happen for
reasons maybe there aren't necessary
beings and this has been you know a
widely accepted point of view among at
least many philosophers and thinkers
ever since then
Bertrand Russell the 20th century
philosopher put it very
straightforwardly he said I think the
universe is just there and that's all
it's a brute fact that's all there
really is to it and basically that's the
position I'm going to defend myself but
I should note that there is sort of a
middle ground on one extreme you have
there is a definite definable point
edible reason for the universe existing
it's God or something else and the other
side of the spectrum you have it just is
stop asking questions in between you
have well the universe didn't have to
exist in this particular way but there
is something nice about the universe as
it is there's something special maybe
more elegant beautiful better this way
of you the universe existing than not
existing of course then you reach that
question why should the universe obey
that principle of elegance or simplicity
or whatever it is but you know maybe
that's a brute fact it's a little bit
slight shift of where the brute facts
are from the existence of the universe
to the thing that the universe satisfies
the kind of criterion that it enables so
that's the history you know in a in a
nutshell very very quickly there's a lot
of people talking about this you see
them talk about it more and more when
the 20th century comes along and
opinions differ you will not be
surprised to learn not everyone agrees
so that's given that history lay some of
the ground work be a little bit more
careful about what we mean by why
something might exist in other words
what we're asking is what do you mean
when you ask why something is the case
what is the kind of answer that would
possibly satisfy you right and this is a
hard question you know we've all had or
at least we've witnessed the experience
of a little kid asking some why
questions why is the sky blue
and someone says well the light from the
Sun is reflected differently whether
it's blue or red and the kid says well
why is the light deflected differently
and you say well it's because of the
molecular structure of the molecules in
the air and how they interact with light
guess what the kid can say well why is
the molecular structure that way and you
could talk about Schrodinger's equation
if you wanted to but usually you just
say stop asking these questions it just
is that way okay so I'm gonna call this
the little kid problem given any answer
to the question why are things one way
you can always ask well why is that true
why is that the case this is what
likeness was trying to wriggle around by
saying that God is the end the buck
stops at God he's necessary you're not
allowed to ask why he exists he exists
for his own reason but if you don't have
that option to go to then you could just
always keep asking more and more
questions in the paper I called this the
problem of explanatory regression why is
this true because of something why is
that true because of something else and
it goes potentially infinitely far
sometimes people like Aristotle said you
know we can't have an infinite chain of
causes why things are true I'm not sure
why that's right I'm not sure why you
couldn't have an infinite chain but
we're not going to dig into those
particular debates right now
so that's a problem that when you have
an answer to a why question there might
always be another why question that pops
up but putting aside that problem let's
just look at the individual answers so
let's bring it down to earth forget
about the universe let's say that the
doorbell rings you open the door and
there's someone there carrying a pizza
so you ask your partner why is there a
person here carrying a pizza at our door
that's a typical Y question that you
might be confronted with in your
everyday life and if you think about it
there could be many many answers to that
there's sort of an obvious answer oh
because I ordered a pizza right that's a
possible answer or you could be a little
bit more specific you know because I
called in a certain way on the phone the
pizza place or because I went on the
Internet but what about things like
because I was hungry what about things
like because we live in a capitalist
system where I'm allowed to exchange
money for goods and services what about
things like because space-time is
four-dimensional I mean if space-time
we're not four-dimensional maybe there
wouldn't be any such thing as pizza and
it wouldn't have arrived right maybe
because gravity is attractive because if
gravity were repulsive we wouldn't have
planets and therefore we wouldn't be
able to live er pizzas if you're this
kind of annoying stickler about what the
why questions might be which by the way
is professionally called a philosopher
if you're that kind of person then you
see there's a multiplicity of possible
answers to a simple question likewise
there's someone at the door
carrying a pizza and of course Aristotle
knew this way back in the day so
Aristotle famously distinguish between
different kinds of reasons why different
things happen different kinds of causes
they're usually called and I don't want
to go into that you know we're not here
to debate
Aristotle or anything like that but for
the purposes of our discussion about why
the universe exists it is nevertheless
useful to distinguish between two
different possible kinds of answers one
kind of answer would be the mechanism
that might bring something into
existence right in the case of the
universe in particular you might have a
physics theory that explains why the
universe came to be through the workings
out of some laws of physics that'll be a
mechanism that brings the universe into
existence
as opposed to that or at least next to
that there is the reason why that
particular mechanism worked at all right
if you have a mechanism that explains
the Big Bang why the universe came into
existence well why is that mechanism
right right this is the more traditional
I think sense of why the universe came
into existence so these roughly
correspond this idea of a mechanism and
a reason correspond roughly to what
Aristotle called the efficient cause and
the final cause there are details that
are different which is why I'm not
getting into Aristotle but I think that
for the purposes of the discussion it is
important to discuss both the mechanisms
that could have brought the universe
into existence if any and the reasons
why that might have happened in the
particular way that it did you'll not be
surprised to hear that talking about
mechanisms is relatively straightforward
that's a physics problem right what
happened at the Big Bang before the Big
Bang or there more than one Big Bang's
these are not easy questions but they
lie squarely within the realm of what we
know and love as physics as cosmology we
know how to talk about these there are
probably equations involved in them the
idea of reasons why the reason why this
particular mechanism worked the reason
why the universe is one way rather than
another is harder this is something that
is not in the wheelhouse of what
physicists do for a living
physicists can say you know gravity is
attractive because of the sign of
Newton's constant in the equations of
motion but if you say okay why what is
the reason why Newton's constant has a
certain sign they might say you know
well it has to do with the stability of
the vacuum state the theory or something
like that but if you keep asking these
why questions like a little kid
eventually they'll just say no that
that's just how it is those are the laws
of physics that we discovered and the
reason for this the reason for the
existence of reasons in this particular
way is that according to the lights of
modern physics would you and I in our
everyday life know as a reason the pizza
guy came because I ordered pizza because
I was hungry
that is not fundamental to how the
universe works unlike what Leibniz had
in mind where the fundamental nature of
reality is a story of
things happening for particular reasons
that is not how modern physics talks
about the universe modern physics talks
about the universe in terms of laws of
physics which are patterns you start
somewhere you start with a particular
state here's the universe with all the
stuff in it doing different things and
then I give you an equation that says
starting from this stuff here's what's
gonna happen next that's true whether
it's Isaac Newton's equation of motion
or Maxwell's equations or Einstein's
equation or Schrodinger's equation this
is the paradigm that physics works under
and at the fundamental level that's the
answer to every why question why did a
person carrying pizza arrived at my door
well because of the laws of physics and
the initial conditions for the universe
at the Big Bang that's a possible answer
you could give that your partner will
not be satisfied with that particular
answer if they're demanding to know why
pizza just arrived you can't just say
yeah it's the laws of physics plus
initial conditions at the Big Bang
you're not gonna be sharing that pizza
very with a happy partner if that's
gonna be the case the actual reasons
that we know and love that we would say
in a more intuitive everyday situation
are emergent they are not fundamental so
if you're talking about the fundamental
laws of physics you're speaking a
language of patterns of this happens
then that happens then that happens then
that happens that's how the laws of
physics work all the talk that we give
about reasons why are at a higher level
of description I talk about this a lot
in my book the big picture it's an
approximation it's a useful way of
talking about the world in sort of a
coarse-grained approximate way the human
scale reality is one where a talk of
reasons why makes perfect sense i order
the pizza because i was hungry
even though words like hungry are
nowhere to be found in the fundamental
laws of physics now some people will
argue that it can't be that way you
can't just remove reasons why from the
fundamental laws of nature because if
you do then all hell breaks loose then
it's just chaos and anything can happen
right you have no explanation for why
one thing happens rather than other so
the distinction I'm trying to draw it's
not that anything can happen it's not
that there are no rules is that the
rules
we call the laws of nature have a very
particular form all they do is say if
this then that if this is the case now
then that will be the case a moment
later they don't say why this was ever
the case they don't say why it's the
case that things evolved in that way
they're just a rule for chugging along
what happens in the universe as time
passes so you can ask why are the rules
that way we don't know that's a that is
very very much subject to the little kid
problem why is the universe why are the
rules one way rather than some other way
you can keep asking that why question so
my point is that the kinds of answers to
questions why is this the case the kinds
of answers that were used to getting in
our everyday context the pizza Kings I
ordered it I order because I was hungry
those kinds of answers might not be
available to us when we're asking
questions about the nature of the
universe itself those kinds of answers
are part of a toolkit that we have for
our everyday lives for the emergent
level of behavior for human scale things
we have no right to demand that the same
kind of reasons the same kind of
vocabulary has any applicability at all
to questions like why is there a
universe what happened at the Big Bang
why are the laws of physics the way they
are there might be answers to those
questions I'm just saying we don't have
the right to demand it we have to be
open minded let's see what happens when
we dig into what those laws are okay so
that's my background about what does it
mean to ask for a reason why when we can
and cannot actually do that now let's go
to the question of what does it mean to
say something versus nothing right what
what do you mean to ask when you ask
about why does the universe exist and
here there's again to sort of sub
questions that we're aiming at one is
the question of you know we look at the
universe we see we can think of the
universe as there's space space is the
arena where things happen right I'm here
someone else is over there there are
planets and stars up there and there's
stuff in the universe me planets stars
and so forth and you can ask why is
there stuff
right you could define nothingness as
not an absence of the universe but as
simply empty space in some sense right
if we had space but no stuff in it that
would be a kind of nothingness would be
like the vacuum in some sense right
maybe there's a question of why there is
matter in the universe this is kind of
the question that we'll check was
getting at when he said maybe nothing is
unstable that's one kind of question the
second kind is why is there a universe
at all why is there space itself forget
why there's stuff in space why are there
three dimensions of space not just vs.
ten dimensions but why other dimensions
of space at all this is harder the
second question is probably what people
have in mind when they're you know live
nits or Hume or rustle or whatever when
they say this question about why the
universe exists why there's something
rather than nothing but it's harder and
therefore there is a common strategy
among people who claim to have answered
the question of why there is something
rather than nothing which is that really
they're answering why there is stuff
inside the universe not why there is a
universe at all these are both
interesting questions so we can talk
about them a little bit but let's just
be clear what's going on we don't want
to claim credit for answering one
question when we're really addressing
another one that why is there stuff in
space versus why is there space at all
so what do we mean by space right I mean
this is you know if you're at this level
of carefulness and asking these
questions some of the easiest most
obvious things that you think you
familiar with need a little bit more
careful consideration to make sure we
know what we're talking about after all
there was this guy Isaac Newton who gave
us a wonderful theory of physics called
classical mechanics I don't think he
called it that maybe he did I don't know
but Newtonian mechanics it's sometimes
called one of the features of Newtonian
classical mechanics is that again
there's stuff in space evolving with
time and that space and time are both
themselves absolute there's something
called space it's absolutely agreed upon
an objective
everyone agrees on what space is
everyone agrees on where things are how
they're moving through the universe
there was an absolute notion of where
you are in the universe
in Newtonian space-time so if you
naively take newton's paradigm he gave
us equations right he said here's how
gravity works here's how inertia and
forces work and so forth
he gave us rules for saying given some
stuff scattered through space how does
it evolve with time time itself is
absolute just like space so again
naively and I keep saying naively
because these are theories right
Newtonian mechanics is a theory
suggested by Newton you might imagine
ways to tweak the theory to slightly
change it okay so when I say naively I
mean what is the most straightforward
direct implication at face value of a
theory like this not that it is an
absolute mess
necessary part of that theory anyway
naively Newton's theory implies the
universe is eternal space and time just
are they exist they extends from past
infinity to future infinity there's
nothing in Newton's equations that says
the universe has to begin or end that
there's stuff moving in the universe and
that will just keep moving forever and
ever
that's the straightforward reading of
dooms equation now Newton himself I'm
not sure if he did believe that or not I
don't know whether he I know that he
thought that God was responsible for the
universe I know that Newton was very
religious in this sense and he was very
happy to talk about how God had
something to do with the universe not
just bringing it into being I mean part
part of what he said was that you know
the the beauty of classical mechanics of
this framework he invented it was so
beautiful it had to be God's design but
he also believed that maybe it wasn't
quite beautiful enough he he was smart
enough to know the kinds of questions he
was interested in were planets moving in
the solar system right explaining the
motion of the planets in the sky and he
was smart enough to know that in his
theory unlike his predecessors Kepler
and Copernicus and so forth
not only did the planets move in the
gravitational field of the Sun but the
planets had their own gravitational
fields so they would influence each
other so they wouldn't simply orbit the
Sun forever they would nudge each other
off of their orbits ultimately the solar
system should be unstable so Newton
actually thought that God would
occasionally come in and clean things up
that he would fix the orbits of the
planets to keep them going for however
long that was necessary again that was
part of his thought that was not popular
later on peer Simone Laplace circa the
Year 1800 was very definite that he
thinks that the universe can be
explained without an interventionist God
that the universe can simply obey the
rules of classical Newtonian mechanics
these rules by the way don't change that
much for our present purposes when it
comes to 1905 when Albert Einstein puts
the final finishing touches on this
special theory of relativity you may
have heard that special relativity says
that space and time are not absolute
anymore they are part of one
four-dimensional thing called space-time
and that's true but in special
relativity space-time is absolute so you
might not agree on where you are in
space but everyone agrees on where they
are in space-time and furthermore that
space-time is just a background it's
there we all live in it and again
straightforwardly if you obey the
equations space-time exists forever it
goes from the past infinity to future
infinity so special relativity doesn't
really change the question why is there
something rather than nothing in either
special relativity or classical
Newtonian mechanics there's just a posit
that here you go this is space or
space-time and there's stuff in it and
it's it's going there was really no
explanatory apparatus that you could
reach for within the theory itself that
did change ten years after special
relativity when Einstein put the
finishing touches on general relativity
in the general theory of relativity now
space-time is still very important the
difference is that space-time is now
dynamical and general relativity
space-time is not a mute fixed
unchanging background
on which everything else happens
space-time is a player in the game the
force of gravity in the general
relativistic way of looking at things is
a manifestation of the curvature of
space-time so when you have matter and
energy that forces space-time to curve
when you have curved space-time that
pushes around the matter and energy and
what you and I know as the law of
gravity when a Apple falls from a tree
Einstein would say that's because the
earth is curving the space-time in the
vicinity of the apple tree so that's a
little bit of an important change for
our present purposes right in general
relativity space-time is not this
separate thing it's not just the stage
on which the drama is being played out
it's an actor in the drama itself and it
didn't take too long in the 1920s people
realized that the universe is expanding
right Edwin Hubble and his collaborators
showed that not only are galaxies moving
away from us which everyone knew Hubble
measured the distances to these galaxies
and discovered that galaxies that are
further away are moving away from us
faster in other words the universe as a
whole is getting bigger and everyone
instantly realized if you wind the clock
backwards if things are moving away from
the future they were closer in the past
and there was a solution to Einstein's
equation that said you know what
everything is just gonna hit some time
in the past some number of years
everything in the universe is on top of
everything else
George lumetri a Belgian priest who was
one of the founders of this idea called
it the primeval atom and today we call
it the Big Bang that moment which we now
know was about fourteen billion years
ago when everything that we know about
in the observable universe was in the
same place according to the equations of
general relativity the Big Bang is a
beginning if you trace what happens
backward in time unlike in Newtonian
mechanics or special relativity and
general relativity there's a singularity
past which you can no longer push the
equations it is no longer true in
general relativity that just because
we're here now and there's stuff in the
universe and it's moving around that
stuff was always here there can be a
moment in
time when the universe comes into
existence and the Pope at the time said
this is brilliant this is just what God
said in the Bible and he asked lumetri
to sort of justify the creation story in
Genesis using these new cosmological
discoveries and lumetri said no that is
a very bad idea
- what if tomorrow someone invents a new
theory where the Big Bang was not the
beginning of everything then we'll be in
trouble so he knew better than to do
that whether or not you have a religious
implication of it circa 1920s the story
seemed to be the universe had a finite
age there's only a finite number of
years between the beginning of the
universe and now and now we know that
number is about 14 billion years well we
don't know is whether or not that was
the beginning because it's an
implication of general relativity under
the right assumptions but you know
general tivity might not be right
general relativity doesn't include
quantum mechanics we need a quantum
theory of gravity maybe there are extra
dimensions of space maybe there are
multi-dimensional branes moving in some
string theory construction many people
including myself by the way have
proposed scenarios where the Big Bang is
the beginning of our local observable
region of the universe but it's not the
beginning of the universe as a whole so
we don't know is the answer to the
question did the universe have a
beginning in general relativity maybe
the Big Bang was the beginning we'll
talk about this in a little bit more
detail later there is a theorem that is
sometimes bandied about the board a Guth
the Lincoln theorem these are my friends
Arvind borde Arvind borde a Alan Guth
Alex Vilenkin some cosmologists in the
northeastern United States and they were
interested in the question of can
inflation go on forever
inflation is a theory where in in the
very very early universe there was a
tiny moment of time when the universe
underwent a hyper fast period of
accelerated expansion so just like we
discovered that our universe is doing
today back then there was this dark
energy essentially that was incredibly
dense incredibly powerful pushing the
universe apart causing this thing called
inflation
and then inflation would end that dark
energy would convert into ordinary
matter and energy and you and I would
see that as the hot Big Bang that we
know and love that's inflationary
cosmology what Guth and valencian and
some other people worked out is that
that inflation can end in some regions
of the universe but it doesn't have to
end everywhere they can end here but it
can keep going other places so they
invented what is called eternal
inflation even if inflation ended for us
somewhere else it's still going on even
today and they asked the question could
this be also true in the past eternal
inflation is eternal toward the future
was it also eternal toward the past so
they wrote down and proved a theorem
that said that as according to the rules
of classical space-time whether or not I
Stein was right about how classical
space-time behaves as long as you
believe in the existence of classical
space-time inflation could not be
eternal to the past so there had to be a
singularity back there rather than just
an eternally inflating universe now if
you google the board a Guth blinkin
theorem the large majority of references
to it are not from cosmologists or other
physicists they are in theological
contexts because people are taking this
as a theorem a proof that the universe
had a beginning that is completely wrong
the board igloo the Lincoln theorem does
not prove the universe had a beginning
it just proves that inflation was not
eternal toward the past it is completely
compatible with the theorem that the
universe bounced at some point in the
past that we live in a baby universe
that came out of something else that we
live in a cyclic universe that bounces
over and over again there's many
different possibilities all of which are
eternal and completely compatible with
the board a Guth Lincoln theorem so we
don't know is the answer to the question
did the universe come into existence if
it did then you'd be forgiven for
thinking that's a good reason to think
something started it right if the
universe started something started it is
a very natural way of thinking it might
not be true but it's a natural place to
go in your thinking but if it lasted
forever then that's a less tempting
place to go honestly we don't know which
one is true
the other thing of course is that the
board at Guth the Lincoln theorem refers
to classical space-time right that is to
say even if there are quantum mechanical
particles in the universe we treat the
universe itself the space-time in which
we live the space-time that obeys the
rules of general relativity as classical
as something is definitely there there's
no uncertainty principle there's no
superpositions of or anything like that
we know most of us know most of us
except the obviously true fact that
that's not right that ultimately
space-time itself is going to be quantum
mechanical just like everything else so
what do we say when we have to combine
quantum mechanics with curved space-time
the answer there is that we don't know
sorry to be telling you things that we
don't know but this is what life is like
on the cutting edge of theoretical
physics and cosmology sometimes they're
to be honest that we don't know the
answer to things so quantum gravity is
something we don't have the answer to in
fact if you're really honest about it
quantum mechanics is something that we
don't really have the answer to quantum
mechanics came along in its final form
in the 1920s and it's a very very good
theory for predicting the results of
experiments as I'm sure you heard
quantum mechanics says that when you
predict the results of experiments you
get a probability not something definite
you say well there's a 50/50 chance the
spin will be clockwise or
counterclockwise or something like that
that's very good we can predict all
these experiments we can use it for
technology we can predict the existence
of the Higgs boson we can go and find it
we can build lasers and transistors and
so forth all based on the predictions of
quantum mechanics what we don't have is
an understanding of what quantum
mechanics really says this is the topic
of a book I'm working on right now
called something deeply hidden which
should be out in fall of 2019 and I'm
sure as time goes on we'll be returning
to the question of quantum mechanics
here on mindscape over and over again
it's a fascinating topic intrinsically
and certainly to me what I mean when I
say we don't understand it is we can
give predictions for certain very
particular situations that will appear
that will pop up in an experimental
laboratory
but we can't tell you what is actually
going on so we can say when I look at an
electron that is spinning and I measure
its spin I'll measure it to be spinning
clockwise or counter clockwise with a
certain probability but if someone says
well what do you mean by measure what
exactly happens when you measure it is
it really evolving differently depending
on whether I measure it or not these are
questions we don't know the answer to
not because we don't have answers but
because we don't agree on what the
answers are as I'm sure I will discuss
in later podcasts I'm a proponent of the
Everitt or many-worlds version of
quantum mechanics which is a terrible
name for marketing purposes I like the
name for descriptive purposes but really
it should just be called pure quantum
mechanics the many-worlds approach says
there is a quantum wave function and
there is nothing else and there's a
Schrodinger equation and there is
nothing else it's the simplest most
stripped-down version of quantum
mechanics now I'm not going to pitch
Eveready in many worlds quantum
mechanics to you right here but I'm
mentioning it because as soon as you
start talking about things like stuff
popping into existence out of nothing or
the quantum vacuum being unstable you
have to have an idea about what quantum
mechanics is right you can no longer be
agnostic about these important
foundational questions so when I talk
about quantum mechanics over the course
of the next few minutes it will be
implicitly in this ever Eddy and point
of view but hopefully that doesn't
matter too much for anything that we say
the point is that in quantum mechanics
we describe stuff not by particles with
positions and velocities but by what's
called the wave function the wave
function in quantum mechanics is
basically effectively we use it as a
tool to calculate the probability of
getting various different outcomes when
you look for the location of electron
where is it going to be
you use the wave function to calculate
the probability some people will say
that's all it is just the tool for
calculating probabilities good Eveready
and we'll say no the wave function is an
exact representation of reality itself
that's what reality is it's a wave
function fine we don't need to debate
that right now the point is a wave
function of what
so when quantum mechanics first came
along people were interested in
electrons orbiting in atoms so you would
have a wave function for an electron you
would have the very first version of
this formalism that was written down by
Schrodinger or when Schrodinger wrote
down the famous Schrodinger equation and
he was just dealing with one electron
moving around the nucleus of an atom and
there you can ask the question you know
going back to our actual topic here can
things appear out of nothing's there
reason why things happen in the
nonrelativistic original baby
Schrodinger equation you're just
describing one electron moving in some
force field of electromagnetism and
electrons never come and go in that
version of quantum mechanics that's
simple down-to-earth version there is
one electron if you observe it you will
see it somewhere and that's the whole
story there is no special help given to
us in this question of why the universe
exists however we know better than that
of course there's more than one particle
in the universe for example there are
fields in the universe there's the
electromagnetic field there's the
gravitational field and so forth
eventually physicists realized that what
we thought were particles like electrons
neutrinos quarks and so forth everything
you and I know and love is a particle is
actually a vibration in some sort of
quantum mechanical field so not only is
there an electric field and a magnetic
field which when they vibrate give us
photons when you observe them there is a
neutrino field which when it vibrates we
see a neutrino when there's an electron
field and it when it vibrates there's an
electron and so forth so the modern best
theory of the universe is called quantum
field theory quantum field theory
describes the universe as a bunch of
gently jiggling fields filling all of
space surrounding you you you you
yourself are an interacting bundle of
gently vibrating quantum fields I hope
that makes you feel good about yourself
the great thing about quantum field
theory is that it can describe not only
the existence of particles as we observe
them but the creation and destruction of
particles
you can make particles when we discover
the Higgs boson with Large Hadron
Collider you don't actually see the
Higgs itself it decays too quickly it
changes into other particles and we see
those decay products that's what can be
described by the formalism of quantum
field theory how particles change into
each other or even how particles are
just created out of supposedly
nothingness so you see how all this
digression is coming back into our topic
that we're talking about here in the
framework of quantum field theory you
can very easily imagine evolution
according to the laws of physics that
starts with empty space space where if
you lived there you would look around
and not see any particles and in the
ordinary evolution of things particles
would come to be this is what Frank will
check had in mind when he said maybe
nothing is unstable it all comes down to
it's not again it's not that anything
could happen if you were in empty space
you don't need to worry that suddenly
particles are gonna pop into existence
they happen under the right
circumstances
so the subtlety here is the definition
of the of the phrase empty space when
physicists talk about empty space
usually what they mean is the vacuum of
a quantum mechanical theory and that's
not a machine that cleans up your room
the vacuum is just empty space in
particular it is the lowest energy state
in quantum field theory if you imagine
you have empty state empty space that
has some energy may be zero or depending
on how you define things if you add a
particle to it to construct a different
state now it has more energy right so
vacuum the technical definition of empty
space is the state of lowest energy the
thing where there's nothing going on but
interestingly there can be temporary
lowest energy States in other words you
can have a state that looks like it's
the lowest energy State but secretly it
can evolve these are called false vacuum
States this is what would drive that
period of inflation that we talked about
if there were a state a false vacuum
that could make the universe accelerate
and then suddenly all of its energy got
converted to particles you would see
particles coming into existence where
there hadn't been any particles
before that is a certainly coming close
to what we have in mind over asking this
question why is there stuff in the
universe then not stuff so all of this
leads up to me saying that may very well
be true so if what you care about is why
is there stuff in the universe then the
answer might very well be found in the
laws of physics as we understand them
now in quantum field theory in the
cosmological applications to quantum
field theory that's the kind of question
we can answer however you might be more
ambitious than that you might want to
know not just why do particles come into
existence out of empty space you might
want to say why does empty space come
into existence and here's where we get a
little bit more wild so let's take a
breath congratulate ourselves on coming
down to some understanding of why there
might be matter in the universe but now
start talking about why there's the
universe itself so the question in front
of us is can the universe simply be all
by itself even if the universe has a
beginning so again we've been a little
bit agnostic about whether or not the
Big Bang really is the beginning of the
universe but we can still ask the
question whether or not the universe had
a beginning does it need a cause does
the universe need something outside to
bring it into existence so the physics
here is that there are two very
different possibilities for the universe
on its largest scale description
according to the rules of quantum
mechanics of course it's always possible
to quantum mechanics itself is wrong
every theory of physics has a chance of
being wrong we should be open-minded
about that but if a quantum mechanics is
wrong then we have no clue what's going
on the current state of physics is
there's zero evidence the quantum
mechanics is wrong in any way so let's
go with quantum mechanics as our theory
so Schrodinger's equation is the
equation we use to describe a system
according to the rules of quantum
mechanics and it works for literally any
quantum mechanical system there are
different versions of quantum
Schrodinger's equation for electrons for
quantum fields for the universe itself
and what Schrodinger's equation is is
basically the quantum replacement
for Isaac Newton's equation that say F
equals MA right force is mass times
acceleration you push something it
accelerates in a certain way the thing
that Schrodinger's equation does is says
you give it a quantum mechanical system
here's how it's going to evolve and the
question is the relevant question for
our present purposes about the existence
of the universe is what is the energy of
the universe this might not be what you
thought you were being asked but this is
what is actually very relevant
Schrodinger's equation acts very
differently depending on whether the
energy of the universe is zero or
nonzero and you might think well that's
easy I've been in the universe I've seen
some things that carry energy so I'm
pretty sure the energy of the universe
is not zero that's a little bit too
quick of course since we're doing the
whole universe it's not just the stuff
in the universe that matters that but
also space-time itself the curvature of
space-time according to Einstein's
general relativity and that counts when
we count up the energy of the universe
and it's very plausible than 100% sure
but in certain very very plausible
versions of cosmological physics the
energy of the universe is exactly zero
if the universe is closed for example if
the spatial topology of the universe is
like a sphere or a torus or something
like that if the universe is finite and
extent then the straightforward
application of what we know about
general relativity seems to imply that
the energy of the universe is exactly
zero we don't know if that's right by
the way it's very easy for that
straightforward marriage of general
relativity and quantum mechanics to not
be right it's very possible the universe
is not closed so there are two
possibilities that are very much on the
table a universe with energy and a
universe without and they have very
different implications for the question
of where the universe came from if the
universe has energy that is not zero and
quantum mechanics is right
so Schrodinger's equation is right then
it follows directly that the universe
has lasted forever there's something
called the quantum eternity theorem I
named it that nobody else calls it that
but just like Newton's
Schrodinger's equation just says the
universe continues forever both from
minus infinity in the past to plus
infinity in the future if on the other
hand the energy of the universe is
exactly zero then there's a puzzling
thing that happens where there is no
such thing as time that's a problematic
thing when you're trying to understand
whether the universe came to existence
if there's actually no time itself
so what Schrodinger's equation says is
how the universe evolves as time passes
and what it says about a universe with
zero energy is that such a universe
doesn't evolve it doesn't change it's
stationary now again you might look
around and say like well I've been in
the universe and I've seen things
changing therefore that can't be right
but again aha
you need to be a little bit more clever
than that people who have studied this
version of the Schrodinger equation
which is sometimes called the wheeler
DeWitt equation after two famous
physicists who studied it in the context
of cosmology a universe with zero energy
and therefore no obvious time evolution
can actually have sort of hidden time
evolution just like reasons why things
happen or emergent in our macroscopic
world the time evolution can also be
emergent in our macroscopic world the
point is you should think about what you
mean when you say the time is evolving
something is happening and you look at a
clock and the clock says oh it's a
certain time and this is what's going on
in the universe and the note the clock
says is a different time something else
and something else is going on in the
universe and this happens on and on an
infinite number of times that's what we
mean by time evolution down at the level
of what we actually see time evolution
is a correlation between some numbers
read out on clocks and some
configuration of stuff in the universe
so in quantum mechanics things can exist
in super positions like that electron
that we were looking at it can exist in
a superposition of spinning clockwise
and spinning counterclockwise so imagine
the whole universe a whole bunch of
stuff scattered throughout space and
some configuration and a bunch of clocks
reading out a bunch of different times
that's one configuration of the universe
there's another configuration where
you know the stuff is somewhere else and
the clocks read different things and
another configuration where the stuff is
in yet a different place and the clocks
read yet different things and in quantum
mechanics the universe the reality of it
all is not any one of those but perhaps
it could be a superposition of all of
them so rather than in this point of
view the universe being described as
something changing through time the
universe could be a superposition of all
individual moments of time in the same
description it's very tempting to say
all at once or at the same time so try
to avoid those temptations because
you're using temporally Laden language
where it's not actually applicable so
the universe could be all moments at
once the universe could be everything
that might happen in a single unified
description and it that's the case then
there's no implication that the universe
lasted forever
if the moments of time that are read out
by a clock are emergent are good
approximations in a certain regime where
we can talk about them then the number
of such moments of time might be finite
that's the thing we would expect to be
true if the Big Bang really were the
beginning of the universe if time has a
beginning in the straightforward sense
it's easier to accommodate that in
quantum mechanics if the universe has
zero energy time is emergent anyway then
you can have a first moment of time now
in either case we have two cases on the
table one is the universe has energy and
alas forever the other is the universe
has no energy and it's finite in time
time is emergent in neither one of these
cases this is the punchline pay
attention neither one of these cases is
there any implication that there needs
to be something outside the universe
that brings it into existence in both
cases a universe that lasts forever or a
universe that is has a beginning a
finite moment of time the description of
what is happening in the universe is
completely self-contained its laws of
physics being obeyed by everything all
the time so even though it's sort of
easier to see as I alluded to earlier
it's sort of easier to see in the
eternal case where things have always
existed there's not this implication
that they sort of were created at any
one moment in the case where somewhere
time itself has a beginning that's where
you had this temptation to say if
there's a beginning there's a creation
and therefore there must be a creator
there must be something outside or to
put it a little bit more colorfully you
say look if you're telling me the
universe popped into existence at some
moment of time you got to tell me why
popped into existence things just don't
pop into existence and the answer is you
shouldn't say the words popped into
existence that's not the right way of
talking about it when you say the words
pop into existence you're already
assuming the time exists right here's
something there's a moment when there is
no universe and then suddenly there's a
moment when there's not in the scenario
where the universe has a beginning where
the Big Bang is the start there is no
moment before the Big Bang the Big Bang
was just the first moment it didn't pop
into existence it's just that if you
think about it from now going backwards
rather than before the universe going
forwards if you start from now and go
backwards you hit an end and that's it
and it makes sense in retrospect that
this can happen in the case where the
universe has zero energy remember energy
is conserved in some sense what that
means is the amount of energy in the
universe is the same at every moment of
time so if you're in a universe that has
energy that in some sense that universe
has to exist forever there's nowhere for
the energy to go if there's one moment
that describes a universe with energy in
it there has to be both a succeeding
moment immediately afterward and a
preceding moment immediately before if
the universe has zero energy then a time
can end then there can be a moment and
there's no creation of anything because
the total energy of the universe is zero
nothing came into existence that always
had been there before so we don't need a
creator for the universe according to
the laws of physics now you might want
to go deeper right you might say well
I'm not about the laws of physics man
I'm about deep metaphysical principles
and my deep metaphysical principles
include something like the principle
sufficient reason that everything that
happens needs a reason so even if you
can have physics equations that describe
the universe as a self-contained system
that doesn't explain the universe and
you know maybe I mean so that's that's a
possible way to go but it's not
necessary so let me give you very very
briefly my reasons why I don't think
that's a necessary direction to go down
the point is as we alluded to do there
need to be reasons why things happen I
told you I try to convince you that what
we understand from physics is that we
can describe the universe even if it has
a beginning or it's eternal as in the
self-contained way we don't need
anything outside see do you need a
reason why in that case well usually the
argument that you do need an external
reason why is simply that a contingent
universe a universe that exists as a
brute fact without any other explanation
violates some cherished metaphysical
principle like the principle of
sufficient reason the way to get out of
it is to imagine there is a necessary
being that necessary being is usually
identified with God and then God's
existence the existence of that
necessary being explains why the
universe exists so then you have to
explain why we should believe in a
necessary being and again I'm not gonna
go into the details here let me remind
you for those of you who went to
Catholic universities like I did and you
heard all the different arguments for
the existence of God from Aquinas and
others there's a cosmological argument
which is basically just a repetition of
the idea that everything that happens
needs to happen for a reason
if something is here there needs to be a
reason that thing exists there need to
be a reason for that you can't have an
infinite number of reasons therefore it
ends in God as I tried to say before
this just begs the question of whether
you actually do need reasons if you're
trying to discuss whether or not things
can simply be as brute facts then
starting with the assertion well we all
agree that everything that happens needs
a reason is not an effective counter
strategy there's another famous /
infamous version of getting to a
necessary being which is called the
ontological argument
which goes back to Saint Anselm and says
we can conceive of a most perfect being
there's different formulations but
that's the basic idea we can conceive of
something that is absolutely perfect and
then it says the having the quality of
existing is more perfect than not having
the quality of existing therefore if we
can conceive of the most perfect being
the most perfect being must exist I'm
probably not doing justice to this
argument it's a hilarious argument no
one has ever been convinced by this
argument many people have believed that
it's true but they already believed in
the conclusion from the start this
there's many ways out of the ontological
argument of this of this idea that we
can conceive of a most perfect being
existence is more perfect than
non-existence therefore the being must
exist necessarily my favorite way out
which is not that popular in the physics
in the philosophy community is just to
say no we can't conceive of a most
perfect being you think you can but
maybe you can think can think you can
conceive of the largest prime number but
you can't because there isn't any such
thing right maybe you think you can
conceive of a circle that we can square
a circle that we can actually
geometrically manipulate into a square
only using compasses and straight edges
but we can't you can't really conceive
of that because we have a theorem that
no such thing exists the point is it's
very easy to fool ourselves into
thinking we can conceive of something
that is just not that well defined what
do you mean by the most perfect being is
that this most perfect being hang around
as it does it talk to us is it more
perfect to talk to us and to not talk to
us is the most perfect being male or
female or is it genderless is it more
perfect to be genderless or to be male
or female is the most perfect being blue
or is it colourless what is most perfect
you haven't actually defined any of
these words which is why we think we can
conceive of it but everyone's conception
might actually be different I don't
think that you can conceive of a most
perfect being I don't think it's a
sensible concept therefore even if you
bought the fact that conceiving of it
would necessarily imply its existence I
don't think you quite get there anyway
that's just a nod to the people who
you know there's really smart people who
take this stuff very seriously and are
convinced by arguments from the
principle of sufficient reason etc that
we need more than just a self-contained
description of the universe and they
might be right but my personal landing
place hears that the universe can just
be it can just be a brute fact so with
that in mind we still have a little bit
to do because even though that's the
answer to the question if the answer is
wise or something rather than nothing
I'm on Bertrand Russell's side I think
the answer is it just is you got to live
with it
you might still ask even if you totally
agreed with me on that one why this
particular universe right why does the
universe exist in this way rather than
in some other way and that's often what
the actual discourse back and forth
about why the universe exists comes down
to people are all arguing about you know
why does it have this number of
dimensions these particles and and so
forth again this is a question why this
particular universe that may or may not
have an answer right I'm a little
skeptical about a certain way of
thinking that many of the world's best
physicists have when they ask themselves
could the laws of physics have been
otherwise right
Einstein himself it's way smarter than I
ever will be Einstein wondered about
this could the laws of physics have been
anything else because I think the answer
is perfectly obvious namely yeah the
laws of physics could have been very
different very easily it's I have no
trouble conceiving of all sorts of
different ways the laws of physics could
have been I'm not even sure if it's
sensible to say the laws of physics
could not have been otherwise thinking
of it in terms of Schrodinger's equation
as we talked about before you know
Schrodinger's equation says there is a
certain special thing the what we call
what physicists call the Hamiltonian of
the universe which is the answer to the
question given some universe how much
energy does it have right that's what
makes the universe go from Schrodinger's
picture and there's all sorts of
different Hamiltonians we could imagine
there's all sorts of different ways we
can imagine assigning different amounts
of energy to stuff in the universe so I
don't even see what the what the pause
well justification would be for arguing
that the laws of physics as we know them
are somehow unique I don't think that's
a really a starter in this argument you
could imagine that if the laws of
physics were unique that would be 90% of
the way to explaining why the universe
exists there was only one way for it to
exist right so maybe it's at least 50%
of the way it was either gonna exist or
not and they had a 50/50 chance but I
think that the universe could have been
very very different than what we
observed so I'm not sure where that
really comes from it is possible that
even if the laws of physics could have
been different
there's nevertheless something special
about the particular laws that we have I
mean maybe the laws that underlie the
universe at the most fundamental level
are somehow the simplest they could be
or the most elegant or beautiful or
something like that now again they don't
look very simple or elegant from our
current point of view there's nice
things about them that are simple and
elegant but you know there's all these
particles the top quark who ordered that
what is that doing there you know we're
not very clear on why the particles have
all the different masses and couplings
they do seems to be a lot of
arbitrariness in the laws of physics as
we know them but maybe that's just our
view of a very messy reality that has
even deeper laws that we don't know
about which are very simple and give
rise to the messiness and apparent
arbitrariness that we observe that's
very very possible I think that really
all we can say there is it's an open
question right maybe we'll eventually
find super fundamental laws of physics
that are even if they're not the only
laws of physics possible or conceivable
they're the simplest or the best in some
way yet to be defined note that would
not explain the question we're after
even if our laws of physics our universe
was the simplest or most elegant or
beautiful the little kid who's our
nemesis here could come along and say
well why why should the laws of physics
be so simple why why is that and we
wouldn't have an answer that would just
have to be a brute fact I also can't get
away without at least mentioning the
idea that the local laws of physics that
we observe local I mean how
entire observable universe tens of
billions of light years across those
those laws of physics might be due to
what is called environmental selection
we tend to think that the laws that we
observe in the universe are universal by
construction but it's possible since we
only observe part of the universe that
the conditions are very very different
elsewhere and if that's true if
conditions could be very very different
elsewhere in the unobservable universe
maybe the conditions out there just
don't give rise to intelligent creatures
such as ourselves this is of course the
anthropic principle but really is just
environmental selection it's the same
principle that says here in the solar
system there's not some deep existential
puzzle about wide life arose on earth
rather than on the Sun or in between the
planets there is an environment here on
earth that was just way more hospitable
to life coming into existence maybe the
universe is like that and if that's true
we would not be at all surprised to find
ourselves in the part of the universe
where life can be allowed to exist it
sort of tautologies its autologous that
if there are many different conditions
in the universe some of which support
life and some of which don't we will see
those that support life what it's not
totally guess is whether or not the
universe is actually like that we don't
know whether there are different parts
of the universe where conditions are
very different elsewhere we also don't
know how robust life is I mean this is
the really big puzzle and this is maybe
food for thought for a different episode
of the podcast how finely tuned are the
laws of physics and conditions in our
local universe for the existence of life
some people think very finely tuned I
tend to be more skeptical more
open-minded about that because I don't
know the conditions under which life
could exist there's a wonderful novel
called Dragon's egg by Robert forward
where he described life existing on the
surface of a neutron star if you think
of life in very general terms as sort of
a complex system interacting in an
informational II dense way with this
environment that could happen under a
whole bunch of conditions that I really
don't know anything about or maybe not
maybe the the necessary laws of physics
are very delicate for something like
that to happen
I think this is another open question
where we should be humble about what we
know we don't know the final answers
here all right
speaking of final answers so here's the
roundup the main points again as James
Hart likes to say what are the options
for the real question not the question
of why there's matter in the universe or
why the you know laws of physics are
this way rather than that way why does
the universe exist at all why is there
something why is there reality rather
than not reality so let me run through
very quickly I think it's five sensible
things you could put forward and I'll
give you my judgments you can give your
own judgments so your own podcast have a
little debate about it that's good
that's why we're here so the most
obvious one is God right this was live
Nance's answer why is there something
rather than nothing because there's a
thing that doesn't need a reason the
universe is contingent it does need a
reason there's something that doesn't a
necessary creature that's God that fits
the role that the principle of
sufficient reason laid out for it I've
told you I don't think that's especially
necessary there's still the question of
is it a good theory right does God
explain does it does it provide an
adequate helpful account of things that
we observe around us that is again a
topic for a different day maybe that'll
be a future podcast episode but my
particular answer is no I don't think
it's especially helpful I don't think
it's especially necessary opinions
differ about that one a second
possibility is what you might call a
meta verse so kind of like a multiverse
but even bigger and I have discussed
this in a detail but the point is if the
difficulty in providing reason why
answers is that there's no context out
of which the universe comes right when
you provide a reason why the pizza
arrived at your door you do so within a
context of things like hunger and pizzas
and phones and Internet's and things
like that and money for the universe
there's no outside context right there's
no bigger picture out of which you can
say oh here the local reasons why so a
meta verse would be a bigger picture
maybe a multiverse but maybe even bigger
than that
so maybe a collection of many men
multiverses and you could say well why
our particular universe came to be in
exactly the same way you would say why
the pizza showed up at your house I
didn't talk about this in a detail I see
zero evidence that that's either true or
necessary or helpful but it's a logical
possibility to put on the table third so
number one was God number two was
Metaverse number three is that there's
some principle that the universe
satisfies right the universe is the
simplest best most elegant prettiest I
don't know I don't think that solves the
problem I think that number one I don't
see any reason that it's true and number
two there's still the little kid saying
well why why should we be the best
universe in any particular way it would
provide some satisfaction to us if that
were true right it would scratch the
explanatory itch if you couldn't really
explain why we lived in the best
universe possible or most elegant at
least knowing that we did would give us
some feeling that we'd accomplished
something oh okay well it's this kind of
universe that kind of makes sense
it doesn't really answer the question
but it provides some of the some of the
mental goal that we were trying to
strive for when we asked the question in
the first place again I don't see it I
don't think it's there but we could find
it that's absolutely possible in the
future
the fourth option which I again didn't
mention at all in this rather long
disquisition but I think is interesting
and and should be talked about more is
the possibility there wasn't an option
for the universe not to exist in other
words we talked about the existence of a
necessary being in God and so forth but
there's another way that you could sort
of slice this bread you could say well
maybe there is simply no coherent notion
of not existing maybe non-existence
doesn't make sense in some sense I'm not
sure how to develop this idea I'm not
sure if it's right I'm up I'm not trying
to promote it I'm a thing I believe it
but I think that you know at least it
deserves thinking about and the reason
why I think it deserves thinking about
is when you read very brilliant people
talking about this question they often
use a vocabulary that doesn't call
cohere that doesn't quite make sense
Derek Parfit who was one of the great
contemporary philosophers who died just
last year in 2017 he wrote about this
question of why there's something rather
than nothing very famously and he uses
phrases like the case where nothing
would have been that's how we talk right
I mean what if what if there were
nothingness but you see what we're doing
and in a phrase like that nothing would
have been or what if there were
nothingness we're attaching being to
nothingness nothing is what was right or
what would have been I'm not sure that
makes sense
I don't think that the thing that exists
being non-existence is a sensible thing
to talk about I think that maybe our
language is fooling ourselves or us here
maybe we are fooling ourselves through
our language I don't know but I think
that philosophers should pay attention
to this possibility a little bit more
carefully and finally fifth on our list
is the universe just is you want to know
why the universe is you're not gonna get
a sacked satisfactory answer you're not
gonna be happy the universe just is you
have to accept it you have to learn to
deal with it there's nothing further
there I like this I mean I don't like it
sort of you know in terms of again like
scratching explanatory itches but I
think it's the one that is most
courageous most brave it faces up to the
reality of it all of these other
attempts hit this little kid problem of
saying well if that's true why is that
true why is that true why is that true
and here you're saying nope there is one
level at which you just say that's how
it is there is nothing other than that
this is what Bertrand Russell was trying
to say I think this is probably the
right answer I know that people don't
like it but whether we like it or not is
not part of how we should judge a theory
of why the universe is the way it is
so maybe the universe is special in
conclusion maybe there's something
special about it that we're going to
find or on the trail of all so maybe it
just is I think we have to be at least
open to that possibility we don't get to
do whatever the right answer is we don't
get to demand that the answer take a
certain form because it makes us happy
that is not what we're allowed to do as
scientists as philosophers as
theologians as thinkers we have to look
at what the universe is doing try to
describe it and understanding the best
and if the answer is the universe is a
brute fact then that's what we have to
learn to deal with and with that in mind
I hope that tonight when you go to sleep
you're not too worried about the
non-existence of the universe and you
can sleep well thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]